[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we'll be taking a look at
some of the characters in the series
that are no longer with us except of
course they are with us
because they're ghosts throughout the
harry potter books and films
ghosts are quite prevalent particularly
at hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
the school seems to be home to quite a
few of them and i've always wondered
how many are there are there any that we
don't know about in this video we'll be
taking a closer look
before we start let's be totally clear
on what characterizes
a ghost a ghost as defined in the world
of harry potter
is a transparent three-dimensional
imprint of a deceased witch or wizard
that continues to exist in the mortal
world returning to the world as a ghost
is not something that muggles have the
option of doing and it is limited to
witches
and wizards those who decide to return
to the mortal world as a ghost
do so because they have unfinished
business this prevents them from moving
on to the next dimension
though they remain in the land of a
living their existence is quite
different from the time
they had during their mortality a
ghost's existence
is very limited in that they no longer
have any sort of physical pleasure
they aren't capable of learning new
things and they harbor any sort of
resentments they had from their
mortality for the remainder of their
existence
rendering them entirely incapable of
moving past things
while they exist and have a semblance of
physical form in the land of the living
ghosts are mostly incapable of affecting
objects beyond water
fire and air in which they can create
disturbances
ghosts pass through solid objects
seamlessly
and the immediate vicinity around them
will feel very cold
additionally witches and wizards are
much more likely to pick up on the
presence of a ghost
than a muggle with all of the above out
of the way let's dive into all the
ghosts that are present at hogwarts
number one nearly headless nick nearly
headless nick was a 15th century
nobleman
who actually attended the school his
full name is sir nicholas de mimsie
pulpington
nick is notably the gryffindor house
ghost and is nearly headless
because he technically still has it nick
was a wizard at the court of henry vii
and fell in love with lady grieve who
was a lady in waiting
when nick attempted to fix her crooked
teeth the spell backfired and grieve
grew tusks instead nick was sentenced to
death
nick is very dramatic and after he died
he even wrote a ballad about his own
demise
entitled the ballad of nearly headless
nick here's the first
verse it was a mistake any wizard could
make who was tired and caught on the hop
one piffling error and then to my terror
i found myself facing the chop
alas for the eve when i met lady grieve
a strolling the park in the dusk
she was of the belief i could straighten
her teeth next moment
she'd sprouted a tusk number two the
bloody baron
the bloody baron was the southern house
ghost and a hot tempered man who would
eventually go on to kill
helena ravenclaw the daughter of rowena
ravenclaw
helena is later known as the grey lady
another ghost of hogwarts that we'll get
into next
the bloody baron's death is quite morbid
as he murdered helena after she refused
his advances
after killing her he took his own life
the chains that the bloody baron has on
him
were an act of penitence for the actions
that he took with helena
an act of penitence as an expression of
sorrow or remorse
for sins number three the gray lady the
great lady is also known as helena
ravenclaw she was the daughter of
hogwarts founder rowena ravenclaw
she is the house ghost for ravenclaw and
was eventually killed by the bloody
baron as i mentioned earlier
helena stole her mother's diadem and
went into hiding in the forests of
albania
interestingly enough these were the same
forests that voldemort would later
frequent
voldemort found the diadem that helena
had hidden in a hollowed-out tree
after finding it voldemort turned it
into a horcrux helena would later
help harry locate the diadem number four
the fat fryer
the fat fryer was a jolly man who looked
like a monk he was the hufflepuff house
ghost and was a hufflepuff himself back
in the day
he has a reputation for being helpful
and kind towards all hogwarts students
he was executed by his fellow churchmen
after the grew suspicious of his magical
abilities
particularly his ability to cure pox and
pull rabbits out of their communion cup
number five professor bins professor
bins aka cuthbert bins
is the current history of magic
professor at hogwarts he taught in
classroom 4f
on the first floor and he continued to
teach their post-mortem
bin's lessons were considered to be some
of the most boring at hogwarts and he
made no effort
to learn his students names calling
hermione miss grant
and harry potter perkins bins slept in
front of the fire in the hogwarts staff
room one night
and died in his sleep the next morning
he left his body behind and got up to
teach as if
nothing had happened it stated that the
most exciting thing to ever happen in
his class
was when he entered the room through the
blackboard number six moaning myrtle
i'm sure you know moaning myrtle she was
a student at hogwarts around the same
time as tom riddle and died to the
basilisk that lived inside the chamber
of secrets
while she was still alive myrtle was in
ravenclaw house and was constantly
teased and bullied at the school
because of her physical appearance
post-mortem myrtle inhabits the first
floor girl's bathroom of hogwarts
in june 1943 myrtle was teased by a
student named olive hornby
this left myrtle in quite a state and
she ran into one of the stalls of the
first floor girl's bathroom
and began crying shortly after entering
the bathroom tom riddle entered and
opened the chamber of secrets
when myrtle heard a boy's voice she
asked him to go away and riddle ordered
the basilisk to directly stare at her
killing her myrtle proves to be quite a
frequent companion to harry throughout
the book's
films number seven sir patrick delaney
podmore
sir patrick delaney podmore also dubbed
sir properly decapitated podmore by
nearly headless nick
was a playful charismatic wizard who was
decapitated subsequently becoming a
ghost
sir patrick was in charge of the
headless hunt which is an organization
of decapitated ghosts that play headless
games
podmore famously denies nearly
headlessness entrance into the
organization
because his head is technically still
attached to his body it has been
speculated
that sir patrick is related to sturgis
podmal who is an active member of the
order of the phoenix
number seven and a half peeves the
poltergeist
what a wonderful kindred spirit i say
seven and a half
ish because peeves is considered to be
according to jk rowling
an indestructible spirit of chaos and
not a ghost
peeves has been at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry since its
inception
in 993 and he is said to have come with
the building
some have speculated that peeves is
simply a manifestation of students
mischief
an embodiment of disorder throughout the
ages peeves has caused all sorts of
mischief at the school
and has been the source of much trouble
the only people able to control
peeves somewhat our fellow ghost the
bloody baron
as well as albus dumbledore peeves was a
considerable source of stress for
groundskeeper argus filch
and the two were sworn enemies for over
25 years
and that concludes the list of named
ghosts however we do know that there are
many more at the school
as shown in the following excerpt from
the philosopher's stone about 20 ghosts
had just streamed through the back wall
fairly white and slightly transparent
they glided across the room
talking to each other and hardly
glancing at the first years the second
indicator that there are more ghosts
is from a passage in the chamber of
secrets the dungeon was full of hundreds
of pearly white translucent people
mostly drifting around a crowded dance
floor waltzing to the dreadful
quavering sound of 30 musical swords
played by an orchestra on a black draped
platform
of course some of these ghosts could
have been from outside hogwarts but
likely not all of them
the bottom line is that there are lots
of ghosts at the school
and that concludes the video i hope you
guys learned a little bit about the
ghosts of hogwarts if i missed any or if
you have any questions
please leave them down below until next
time there is plenty to be learned even
from a bad teacher
what not to do how not to be
[Music]
you